Automoto a essayé la Toyota SR coupé
deux portes de la série Corolla
remarquant au passage le volume du
coffre qui ne permet pas le chargement
de nombreux bagages
côté moteur de la simplicité efficace 4
cylindres en ligne de 1166 cm3 refroidie
par eau alimentation par deux
carburateurs double corps arbre à cames
en tête un mot sur le freinage assuré
par 10 à l'avant et tambour à l'arrière
en fait rien que du classique ayant fait
ses preuves
à l'intérieur équipement tout à fait
complet bien disposé aussi bien pour les
essuie-glaces que pour la commande
d'éclairage
[Musique]
la boîte de vitesse est un modèle du
genre les 83 chevaux du moteur sont
constamment votre disposition et
maintenant test 0 100 km heure
[Musique]
en montant les régimes à 6600 tours la
voiture pousse très fort et
malheureusement la sonorisation laisse à
désirer toute conversation devient
pratiquement impossible à l'intérieur de
l'habitacle
100 0 à 100 15 secondes de dixième
la dureté de la suspension sont mauvais
revêtement amène un léger sautillement
du train arrière et ce sûrement dû à la
brusque détente des amortisseurs sur
l'autoroute à 130 km/h il reste de la
réserve sur le pied pour une 7 chevaux
20140 francs en main c'est beaucoup
[Musique]